hello everyone and welcome back to some
rapid action unleashes by now you
already know everything uh so let's dive
straight into it in the previous game we
got the white pieces so most likely we
get black today uh let's see what we get
and uh I will try to play a little bit
faster so I don't run into time trouble
but again it's important that I um
explain everything well and then you
know if I have time to to finish it I
will if not I'm still considering you
guys are you know saying that maybe I
should add like a second increment or
maybe even a 5sec increment but um you
know 10 minutes is is a lot of time
let's um I I will try to become faster
so our opponent is daliri and we're
going to start with
E4 okay so it's the caroan uh do we try
what Magnus tried in the title Tuesday
or do we just stick with what we know I
I still haven't uh worked it out yet um
because there are some tricky lines uh
so we're just going to uh stick with the
standard caroan and uh yeah these are
you
know standard moves now he can capture
with the G Pawn or with the E Pawn uh G
capturing with the G Pawn uh does give
you a very very nice game and that is
what he's going for so uh all right
let's uh yeah let's trade off this light
Square Bishop it
is what what he's going for and we're
going to go Knight to E2 we're going to
maybe put the Knight to F4 uh and Castle
uh yeah okay so he will definitely be
cast Ling Queen side it doesn't matter
that the G file opened up uh so let's
challenge this
bishop yeah okay let's put it to
G3 and let's Castle Queen side same as
him okay we're going to play King to uh
we should play King to B1 and sometimes
even King to A1 okay so he wants to open
up the yeah he's playing very very nice
moves here not spending a lot of time
and we're going to have to figure out
how to go about this all right I'm going
to pressure the F6 spawn here not sure
if it's the way to go but
uh yeah looks nice and if he captures I
can get my knight into the game if
he yeah queen queen F5 does look like a
nice move does a a sort of pin that
Knight does it's not really relevant
yeah he can just move the king and the
Knight is defending uh but yeah let's
uh how how to proceed here we have to
figure out uh some sort of a realiz ible
plan yeah capturing NE never really
interesting for
me uh because it just UND doubles his
pawns and those are those are you know
future weaknesses that we can hone hone
in on so let's just uh get the Rook to e
file and now we should figure out how to
improve the position over our Knight as
much as possible he might go for some H5
H4 action that definitely makes sense
and if I move the H Pawn then I weaken
my structure so it's a fun position
position uh one that uh requires uh
delicate consideration at every point
but know every position yeah he does go
for H5 uh
so uh probably since he has double F
pawns I'm going to play H4 and if he
captures we're going to trade and put a
Pawn on G3 and that the way we have this
structure he has a double F Pawn so he
can't really put pressure on my F Pawn
so yeah we're going to go with H4 I'm
not too happy about it I would prefer
the pawn to remain on H2 but uh yeah I
feel like I should play it okay so what
to do to improve without
uh where does the Knight belong he the
Knight definitely belongs on D3 for the
moment but yeah maybe not even on D3 but
definitely not on E2 so let's just move
the
Knight we'll figure it out later I don't
want to play uh Knight to D3 before it
capture happens because I want to have
the option of recapturing with my
Rook yeah okay so he does go for this
we're just going to capture
here and uh I don't know this does look
like something that I would
enjoy huh sort of a free doubling of the
Rooks and I don't see why he would allow
that you now now Queen C7 I can even
play Rook E7
could be a bit dangerous to get my Rooks
uh up the board but uh yeah I maybe I
mean objectively it should still be a
perfectly fine position for him like if
I double up here I'm not really pinning
anything he can just move the Knight and
a trade on the on d8 is nothing his
Queen will be guarding the F6 Pawn so I
I can't even win material if I try that
but Rook to F7 might Rook to E7 might
be uh might be a more interesting
approach so so yeah let's go with
that sort of take away take away squares
from his Queen and now if he offers a
trade I don't know if I can capture and
allow Rook to E1 looks a bit
dangerous
uh but no if he plays this then this
just wins yeah he can't play
that yeah tactically that that that will
not work for him and he has to figure
out how to go about this yeah okay so he
he self pins and now we can just bring
the Knight into the game because now if
our Knight can land on C5 that's
game uh also we can start collecting
material and
also what's the best
way is there a difference do I go via D3
or
B3
yeah I'm going to go via
D3 okay so he does go for this because
now it is
possible uh but at least now we cover
the E1 square with our Knight so that's
why D3 was slightly slightly
better but no it is still just a
blunder yeah it's still just a
blunder is it the blunder what am I
missing something here what's what's
stopping me from taking the piece I have
blundered in some of my previous games
so I should
definitely uh be careful but yeah I mean
I don't see
it I don't see
it yeah so we're just going to be up a
piece and uh yeah
it's know it does appear to be a pretty
clean game
uh I don't know it's a I I I've never
actually studied the G captures on F6
line I I know some uh interesting ideas
in the E captures an F6 line so he goes
for this yeah
uh there there's not nothing more he can
do
here yeah but whatever he
tried
uh just doesn't matter yeah he does have
one check but that's all there
is
okay yeah I don't know uh the fact that
he allowed me to double out you know I
didn't double up but he allowed me sort
of uh uh free moves with my Rooks I
could choose between doubling up on the
D file and then the E file uh appeared
to be a bit too
much yeah okay so um yeah I guess he
will play
this yeah
okay so uh what's the cleanest way to
win let's just play G4 and Advance our H
point to victory that seems like uh you
know without uh thinking too
much yeah he'll maybe give a check but
doesn't really matter yeah this is a I
very rarely resign but this is a
position uh uh that that you can resign
but still you you can learn a lot from
this uh sometimes uh you know people do
make mistakes even even in top Grand
Master games people do make mistakes uh
when it's uh so do we do we think about
something
here yeah not
really doesn't matter how far he
advances the pawn there's just no
continuation whatever he
does yeah but it's uh of course it is
possible you know you don't you don't
want to give up rating for
nothing if if there's a possibility I
make a mistake of course you should
continue let's go
H7 and now he advances the pawn I can
even pick up the Rook so
yeah if not we're just going to give a
check and uh promote our
Pawn all right but uh yeah I'm I'm very
interested uh where he made the critical
mistake okay so we'll just pick up the
Rook uh where he made the critical
mistake but but I think it's the moment
where he allowed the sort of the free
movement of my Rooks yeah okay
okay yeah okay so we'll take the queen
so he will also he's banking on uh he's
banking on M taal mating him all right
so we're going to go here and if he
brings a queen into the game we're just
going to deliver Checkmate
here yeah okay he brings the knight in
fine all right good game Mr or Mrs
deliri uh let's check out what uh what
actually happened here so the Carl KH
pretty standard stuff where black has
many options sometimes Black Goes Bishop
F5 sometimes Knight to F6 sometimes even
Knight B to D7 uh everything can be
played for those of you who are maybe
new to chess if sometimes you will
encounter Knight bd7 and then you can
trick your opponent with Queen to E2 and
if he delivers this Knight here you can
deliver this quick Checkmate I've
actually done this many many times uh
not proud of it but you know uh so okay
this is what happen C3 he played Bishop
okay uh Knight to F3 obviously the main
way to go the the early trade of the
light Square Bishops might not be all
that uh ambitious for white but yeah
since I don't know yeah I went back so
capturing a little bit better okay uh
seems like uh captur captures and queen
G3 is the way to go I decided to play
Bishop to G3 so okay Castle castles King
B1 H5 that's fine yeah and here with D5
uh he sort of rushed it and it's uh yeah
I should even capture here and then
after Knight captures Queen F5 check
okay King B8 captures here okay so I can
win a pawn okay I missed that but uh I
don't know if I would even go for that
if I knew it was best cuz I mentioned
the game uh that you know the my sort of
a reference game for the caroan on the E
captur F6 line the game Duda played
against Magnus Duda got a winning
position like very early on like for
move 10 and uh he won the game but the
position that he had to play was so
disgusting yeah I played H4 sort of
Bishop to H4 yeah see the engine always
wants to go after this F6 Pawn I just uh
I don't know I just don't think like
that yeah so
H4 uh yeah okay so REM maneuvering of
the Knight the way to go captures
captures yeah and here yeah the engine
sort of gives a plus one
1.4 uh but after this capture and the
move that we discussed yeah I'm
completely winning here with a plus 2
2.5 yeah captures captures yeah Rook E7
best uh bringing the Knight to D3 also
best and now Rook capture yeah sort of
a yeah sort of an engine perfect game
for me that's
uh uh quite quite a surprise but uh a
pleasant one you know it's not like I'm
going to I'm going to blunder a piece
every game I play uh so yeah that's the
game hope you guys enjoyed it hope you
you learned something about what to do
and what not to do like I said I I don't
know uh many many lines I know you know
General ideas behind the opening
sometimes I will of course go for
suboptimal lines uh but uh that's not
the point of these videos the point of
these videos is to give lower rated
players and players who are trying to
improve uh General ideas on what uh what
happens uh in the mind what is my mind
process when uh considering certain
moves and sometimes I will get in time
trouble for that but uh yeah here we we
we turned out okay uh so yeah that's the
game hope you guys enjoyed it thank you
D Dei for uh you know uh playing this
game with me and yeah as usual you can
check to my previous videos here thank
you for watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World see you
soon